Being a little more formal now,
we define P to be the set of problems
solvable in polynomial time.
By polynomial time, we mean that
the number of Turing machine steps
is bounded by a polynomial.
We'll formalize this more in a moment.
Bipartite matching was one example
of this class of problems.
NP we define as the class of problems
verifiable in polynomial time.
This includes everything in P, since if
a problem can be solved in polynomial
time, a potential solution can
be verified in that time too.
Most computer scientists strongly
believe that this containment is strict,
that is to say, there are some problems
that are efficiently verifiable, but
not efficiently solvable.
But we don't have a proof for this yet.
The clique problem that we considered is
one of the problems that belongs in NP,
but we think does not belong in P.
There's one more class of problems that
we'll talk about in this section on
complexity, and
that is the set of NP complete problems.
These are the hardest problems in NP,
and we call them the hardest because any
problem in NP we can efficiently
transform into an NP complete problem.
Therefore, if someone were to come
up with an polynomial algorithm for
even one NP complete problem,
then P would expand out in this diagram,
making P and NP into the same class.
Finding a polynomial solution for
clique would do this.
So we say that clique is NP complete.
Since solving problems doesn't
seem to be as easy as checking
answers to problems, we're pretty
sure that NP complete problems
can't be solved in polynomial time.
And therefore, that P does not equal NP.
To computer science novices,
the difference between matching and
clique might not seem to be a big deal.
And, it's surprising that one is so
much harder than the other.
In fact, the difference between
the polynomial solvable algorithm and
an NP complete one, can be very subtle.
Being able to tell the difference
is an important skill for
everyone who'll be designing
algorithms for the real world.